welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
happy one day post st
patrick's day two days post my mother's
60th birthday
in this episode i spoke with dr mark
hyman we talked about his new book
the pagan diet we spoke a bit about what
a healthy diet looks like
obviously we have differing views of the
carnivore diet
but a huge overlap in what the major bad
foods are
we spoke about dairy rebuilding gut
health chronic stress
viral immunity raising kids on the
proper diet the theory of the board
immune system and more
mark hyman is an american physician and
new york times best-selling author
he's a practitioner of functional
medicine please remember to hit
subscribe if you enjoy this content
this episode is brought to you by true
local that's where i get most of my meat
i've been on a lamb kick for the last
year they have excellent lamb
although their steaks are very good too
what they do is they partner with local
farmers and butchers in your area to
source some of the best meat things like
100
grass-fed and grass-finished beef
pasture-raised
or rwa chicken rwa means raised without
antibiotics for those who don't know
lamb bison and over 100 different cups
of meat that you probably can't find at
your grocery store
you build your own personalized box that
will give you enough meat for the month
with only the products you want
and it shows up at your door
with code mp you get free stakes with
your box
trulocal.ca check them out
please enjoy this episode
[Music]
dr mark hyman welcome to my podcast well
thanks for having me
uh could we just get started i know
you've you've come out with this
new book recently the pagan diet and
that's what i want to talk to you about
you didn't take pagan from paleo no it's
not
pagan no it's people god people do that
all the time don't they
vegan with a pee okay to tell you the
truth though
i was saying pagan and then my sound guy
said pagan
and i was like oh okay so really it's
it's
it's his fault it's okay we'll forgive
you
uh can we can we start off by you just
for anyone who doesn't know who you are
who's listening can you give a brief
background about who you are and what it
is that
you do sure i'm a doctor actually a real
doctor i went to medical school
i have practiced functional medicine for
the last 30 years which is looking at
root causes of disease and really
understanding that food is medicine
and also they're all different and that
really functional medicine is very much
personalized medicine and personalized
nutrition
and i've you know been doing that for a
long time and have my own practice and
linux at the ultra wellness center i run
a center cleveland clinic and
written about 17 books and 13 new york
times bestsellers and
generally trying to raise awareness
about food as medicine and functional
medicine so i'm
very excited about that i i'm also
working on a non-profit that helps to
change food policy and ag policy to
bring us more healthy real food oh wow
that's big
good luck in the states
sounds complicated yeah it's a big job
yeah uh okay can we start off by um you
giving a bit of a
background on what the pekin diet is
what that means
sure well you know it sounds like a
funny name but it was actually a joke
i was sitting on a panel with a friend
of mine who was a vegan cardiologist
another one was a paleo doctor and they
were fighting like cats and dogs and i'm
like well if you're paleo
and you're vegan i must be peaking i
already laughed i thought oh that's a
good joke
and then i started thinking about it on
the way home and the plane i'm like wait
a minute they're identical
uh they have far more in common with
each other they do the traditional
process diet while eating and then
they're identical except for where they
get their protein which is animals or
grains and beans otherwise they both say
we should eat real food on processed
food we see lots of vegetables she lets
the seeds good fats we should
not add all kinds of hormones
antibiotics pesticides gmo and
everything to our diet
that we should be eating you know just
good food and i think that's really
uh what i started to think about wait a
minute we all need to come up with a set
of principles
that guide us around healthy eating that
is good for us good for the planet good
for the animals
and and that's really the purpose of the
pagan diet is to set forth a set of
principles that
are ground in science that combine with
common sense and give us a set of
practical ways of choosing food
not based on dogma or ideology but based
on on what really works for each of us
and i think that's that's often what
happens is that our
our ideology our beliefs sort of trample
our biology
and so you know well i should be a vegan
because it's good for the planet
but actually if you're a vegan you might
have a constitution that doesn't really
do well
or you think oh i should be really low
fat because that's really
you know bad i think that's bad and then
you might find that maybe you become
diabetic if you are
someone who's carbohydrate intolerant so
you got to really think about what is
your personal requirements for health
and how does your body respond to
different ways of eating but within that
there are
a set of guiding principles and that's
really why the title of the book is the
puke and diet 21 practical principles
for reclaiming your health in a
nutritionally confusing world because
they're also confused
very very very confused especially the
more diets that come out
what what are the main foods if people
could do just a few things to get their
health under control what are the main
foods you suggest people will not
eat yeah so i think it's it's you know
it's interesting we're in a pickle
because of one what we do eat
which we shouldn't and what we don't eat
which we should right so we should
not be eating industrial processed foods
60 of our calories
in in america and increasingly around
the world are from multiple processed
food
this is food that's made from pulverized
ingredients from
corn wheat and soy that are turned in
all sizes color shapes have extruded
food-like substances that
are nutritionally depleted and have
really nothing to do with with our
well-being
uh and they're really ways of driving
you know profits for for big food
companies
on really cheap ingredients and so we've
got to get away from all that industrial
crap if basically if
my rule jokingly is you know ask
yourself a simple question did god make
this
or nature if you don't believe in god or
did man make this you know did god make
an avocado
yeah did you make an almond or an egg
yeah
do you make a twinkie or skittles or
twizzlers no
you know i mean it's not that hard to
sort of figure out what to eat if you
just follow basic simple ideas of
quality and i think that's the other
kind of piece around this is that
you know we need to think about what is
what is quality so one you want to get
rid of the
sort of processed food which is the
flour the sugar
the high fructose corn syrup trans fats
all the food additives chemicals
pesticides all that stuff that just
instant food
and stick with with food and what what's
really
uh striking when you do that is that it
it ends up being
profoundly effective in helping people
deal with all kinds of chronic health
issues weight issues
i mean there isn't even a chapter in the
book on weight loss because it's
automatic when you take care of your
health
if you get healthy getting rid of your
diseases and the weight loss is just a
side effect
yeah what do you do for people okay so
from what i mean you know that i've
i've been on the carnivore diet for
three and a half years um
and and that's taken off um and the
people i've seen
do well on that generally the only
people who bother trying it are
so ill that they're just like half
dead they're like well i guess i'll
guess i'll try this so
what what uh two questions what are your
suggestions for people who are just
trying to eat healthy i think we went
over that a little bit just general
rules
what do you do with people who are
really really sick like
autoimmune disorder sick or mood
disorder sick
yeah well that's a great question
because you know the basic premise of
the vegan diet is that food is medicine
and we can be very specific about how
we choose different foods for different
people it's not like one medicine is
going to cure all diseases we
we really can customize and personalize
nutrition based on that
and and you know what functional
medicine is is really treating very very
sick people with food as medicine
so it's not like a a throwaway
back-up plan if the drugs don't work it
actually works better than the drugs
uh i just get an example of a patient
who came to see us at cleveland clinic
and she was
pretty pretty much on her way out she
was type 2 diabetic she was
had a body mass index of 43 meaning she
was just
enormous you know over 25 is considered
overweight over 30 is obese
and she had type 2 diabetes heart
failure angina kidneys were starting to
fail liver starting to fail
i mean just pretty much everything and
she was on a pile of medication
um and was really struggling within
three days of changing her diet
she was off her insulin within three
months she was off all her medications
and reversed all her diseases
and this was someone who was really sick
it wasn't like she had some mild
problems she had very advanced diabetes
she had advanced heart failure she
kidneys were starting to fail and all
that could be changed by
giving her food that helped her body
heal and removing the food that harmed
her body
and that's really all it is and it's
it's understanding how to do that and
she for example need a very low starch
sugar diet
more fats get rid of common food
allergens anti-inflammatory foods
foods that help her microbiome so it's a
whole strategy of how to use food as
medicine
autoimmune disease is the same thing you
know we find that you know autoimmune
diseases are complicated it can be
caused by many things
it can be caused by infections like lyme
disease it can be caused by toxins like
mercury
uh it can also be caused by our leaky
gut which is probably one of the most
common reasons and
in a lot of the reasons uh you know that
that happens is because of gluten in our
diet
and gluten is a very damaging component
that's found in wheat and
other grains and for some susceptible
people it really drives autoimmune
disease so
the thing is when people are go to a
carnivore diet they'll often feel better
just like when they go to a vegan diet
if they're eating a traditional
processed diet and they swap out
anything for all the crap you're going
to feel better and i think
they're you know when you're when you're
done a carnivore diet you're often
eliminating a lot of the things that are
problematic for people grains beans
dairy sugar processed food i mean you're
just getting rid of all that
and so maybe it's not only what you're
you know adding the meat maybe it's more
what you're getting rid of that's
creating inflammation in the body so i
think
that you know we were still learning
more and more about it and you have to
see what works for you
and where you're getting your nutrients
i mean if you're really in a carnivore
diet you need to make sure you're eating
a lot of organ meats to get a lot of the
vitamins for example like liver and if
you don't do that you're probably not
getting all the nutrients you need for
example
so it's it's it's really about how do
you personalize and customize it for you
yeah here's so here's the funny thing
like i so
i i read your book and um the outline
you give for what vegetables consume
to consume i actually started off on
that when i
cut everything from my diet and i went
into remission i went off of
all my medication and i was eating i was
pretty much eating what
would you suggest which was really heavy
vegetables with some meat because i
actually just
like salad and vegetables so and and i
went into remission and i was in
remission
um as long as i didn't add in certain
things like i couldn't do beans at all
but um but keeping like
vegetables salad vegetables root
vegetables
yeah and some protein i was doing really
well
and then i got pregnant and i took a
round of
really probably really toxic antibiotics
i kind of did that at the same time and
for a while i blamed the pregnancy
because i lost my tolerance for all
these
vegetables during the pregnancy but then
i realized about a month before i got
pregnant i had this round of
really strong antibiotics um called dap
zone which they used to treat
like yeah so yeah
so what do you do say you have serious
gut damage and i talk to a lot of people
who
who have gone from something like meat
and greens and a fairly healthy diet to
a carnivore diet because
they're still sick and that's improved
their symptoms but these people
nobody really wants to stay on it so
there's an idea of you know heal your
gut and reintroduce foods and
manage to get back to a little bit more
variation so
where do you start if everything bugs
you
well i think it is you sort of have to
pare back and i think the key is you
know
not only eliminating what you're
sensitive to but fixing
why you're sensitive and that's really
the purpose of functional medicine is
how do you actually
identify what the root causes are and
work on those
which is is not that you're necessarily
inherently reacting to all these foods
but your gut has become damaged
i need to mention the antibiotics you
mentioned pregnancy various things can
create
insults that damage our gut even further
and you know it's it's our
it's our current modern life right our
c-section rates are about a third of all
births you know we have formula fed
babies that don't have the beneficial
prebiotic fibers that are in traditional
breast milk
we overload our kids with antibiotics we
pile on immunizations nothing
immunizations are bad it's just a lot of
stress on the immune system
at a very early age you know we have
food that's highly processed
we've had food that's doused in
glyphosate which is a microbiome
destroyer
we're exposed to other environmental
toxins which damage our gut
uh you know we eat we eat all these
additives and emulsifiers and chemicals
about five pounds per person year of
chemicals in our diet that also can
damage the gut-like carrot gene in
and they go i'm just having a little dye
red dye in my twizzlers or whatever like
but
it adds up you know literally three to
five pounds a year of food additives
um and so when you do this you damage
your gut
and so the key is how do you then
rebuild your gut and this is really the
science of functional medicine you have
to eliminate the things that are
a problem and you have to also add in
things and you need to heal the guts you
need to clear out the bad bugs you need
to
i call it the weeding seeding and
feeding program and often that's often
missed for people because they go i'm
just going to eliminate these foods and
i have to be out these forever but it's
really not the whole point is it's
become more resilient
healthier robust so you can withstand
various kind of insults or stresses so
if you eat a piece of gluten it's not
going to put you in a coma
and i think or give you arthritis or all
right
to say some people actually may be
celiac or maybe really
severely gluten sensitive and need to be
offered forever but
most of my patients you know and i i've
personally experienced this but i when i
had mercury poisoning and my whole
system was screwed up and i had leaky
gut and
bacterial overgrowth and i had
autoimmune stuff going on
i i really couldn't eat anything like
without my stomach just blowing up and
feeling like crap and getting dark
circles in my eyes and rashes
and it was my tongue would get sore it
was almost like the worst thing ever
i mean i'd eat turkey i think i did
turkey turkey and broccoli and
brown rice for like six months i mean
that was bad you know
but now i'm pretty robust and i've
learned how to repair my gut and heal
that he got and have normal digestion
and i actually don't have really
reactions when i have food now
with that said i will if i i will have
reactions if i eat
uh processed food like if i eat
processed food my tongue gets a little
very weird and i can feel the chemically
nature of it i'm just
super sensitive to it but i think that
for the most part i can pretty much eat
anything now
given how much i've learned how to
repair my gut and that's the key is
not not only what are you sensitive to
but why are you so sensitive and fixing
that
yeah 100 i've been completely aware i've
like cut out everything i know how to
be completely asymptomatic i've been
asymptomatic for
years now um but something's bugging my
immune system
and i have i tested positive for lyme
disease which is just another
you know another thing what what are
these what do you do if you're stuck
with some sort of infection
oh well like you know your immune system
plays a huge role right so i think
uh what most people don't realize is
that there's two parts to infection one
is the bug and the other is the host
uh which is your own constitutional
well-being and you you literally can
take
and they've done these studies and i
think with covet it's probably the same
you could take
a cold virus you literally inject it
into people's noses or they're getting a
full dose of cold virus
if they have high levels of stress they
get sick
if they don't they might not get sick so
not everybody exposed to the same thing
gets sick and that's because of the host
and it depends on your
overall nutritional status your levels
of stress how much sleep you've had what
your
vitamin levels are if your vitamin d is
adequate or not zinc levels vitamin a
i mean i think most people don't
understand that our nutrition plays a
massive role in our immunity
and then with cobit we're seeing the
fact that people are so susceptible to
coba because they're overweight or obese
or have
chronic diseases which are related to
this sort of diet
and i think with with the autoimmune
issues
you know i think we we um we have to
look at
what all the factors are because it's
not only diet like i said
it can be viruses it can be a tick
infections like lyme it can be
heavy metals or other factors so you
know you start with food because that's
easy
but if you're not better then you need
to kind of go down
a level you know that patient would say
to me hey dr hyman is impossible i just
did this
elimination diet for 10 days and my
rheumatoid arthritis is almost all gone
i'm like
is that possible i'm like yeah it's
possible if it's what you're eating but
if you have lyme disease and then you
wouldn't get better or if you had
mercury you might get a little better
so it's really about figuring out what's
right for you
okay um i had i had covert in the summer
and it was boy yeah it wasn't i was
i was very concerned because when i used
to be very ill i used to get bronchitis
every year i was on immune suppressants
and it just knocked me out for like
it'd be like five months of bronchitis
and then i'd get hit with three rounds
of antibiotics and i'd end up in the
hospital and then i'd get better and
then it would happen again the next year
and i was like if i get covered bad
things are gonna happen
and it was okay it was like three and a
half
two and a half weeks of like a flu um
but i was surprised i was surprised that
i i managed to
to handle it okay so that was nice
um there was something i wanted to ask
about you what you just said but
okay well how about how about this we'll
just we'll just change topics for one
sec although i want to go back to that
um how do you feel about dairy
so i think you know i think dairy is a
nature's perfect food
um but only if you're a calf
i think it's problematic for for many of
us uh
and here's why one um about 75
of the global population is lactose
intolerant after childhood so that's
number one number two you know the the
dairy we're eating
now is not the dairy we used to eat so
these cows are
often hybridized to be identical there's
sort of hosting dairy cows
they have a type of of casein which is
the protein
milk called a1 casein which is very
inflammatory
more likely to cause digestive issues
has been linked to things like
osteoporosis
and also even um
things like autoimmune diseases like
type 1 diabetes cancer
it's it's it's been problematic in
looking at the data on this and there's
there's a there's a wonderful article
people are confused about whether milk
is healthy or not
from the new england journal medicine
which is a very conservative
journal by two of the top nutrition
scientists in the world at harvard
uh and it's called milk and health and
you can just google it milk and health
new england journal medicine
and have a read on that because
basically it breaks down all the
nonsense about what we used to think
that it's great for your bones
you actually may increase the risk of
fractures uh this need to grow it's
really not and most cultures don't have
milk
or milk after weaning and i think you
know
i think most people i find in my
practice do better without dairy it can
cause acne it can cause
digestive issues can cause autoimmune
issues eczema skin problems allergies
so often i really get people off it as
an initial start
but then if people want to have it i
think you know all dairy is not
necessarily bad but
if you have sheep or goat milk it's
often a2 casein or
cheaper goat yogurt or cheese so that's
an alternative or there are a2 casing
cows which
are more heirloom cows so
i think it's really important to
understand that we need to pick the
right dairy and this is the same in
everything in the book so how do you
pick the right meat the right dairy the
right vegetables the right grains the
right beans and that's
what i go through because quality really
matters so a
a a pregnant cow growing a feedlot
you know milked with hump full of
hormones and antibiotics
eating a diet this high in refined i
mean in
corn and and processed ingredients even
they feed these cow skittles and ground
animal parts and poop
you know how is that different than
having like some
goat milk from some goat that's been you
know running around eating wild shrubs
and
actually having very high levels of
beneficial chemicals in them and so
it's really different about what you eat
and the quality that matters
i found well i never ate like terrible i
in this i find that it's easier to get
really really low quality meat in the
states
to be honest i i never really i never
went there so i can't really talk about
my experience
my experience with grass-fed grain
finished beef in canada has been has
been fine although now i'm eating a lot
of lamb
and that seemed i seem to be doing
better actually with lamb and i think
that's
yeah like i completely healed with grass
fed not completely
i healed so that i was asymptomatic
autoimmune wise
with grass-fed grain finished beef
but my digestion was always not great
and i couldn't figure out why and it
turns out this beef fat
was causing it so it would have been
worse with some broths and
and it took me like two years to figure
out because because i was like i started
incorporating lamb and was like oh you
know things are a little bit better and
then i switched over to lamb and leaner
cuts of beef and
like there there we go i guess that was
that was it for me um
although i've managed to incorporate
some other things in and i'm varying my
diet
what did you do to be able to go from
having
you know kind of chronic health problems
and not being able to eat very many
foods
to being able to eat foods did you do
some sort of
protocol where you rebuild microbiome or
kill off the bad guys
yeah yeah so yeah absolutely so i did i
mean it was many years of treatment but
i had to get rid of the heavy metals
which were disturbing my gut first so
that was really key and and then i've
developed a strategy of how to rebuild
people's guts over the years and i think
you know i've learned a lot of things in
functional medicine and
i recently you know my uh curse and
blessing you could say
is that i tend to get everything and
then i have to figure it out just sort
of like you did which
leads to what you're doing in life but i
developed from an antibiotic that i took
for a bad tooth colitis
something called c diff which is a
terrible injection oh
it's terrible that's fun no fun no fun
at all
and then and then i had to see different
then i developed colitis after that and
my whole gut was just a mess and i was
going to the bathroom 20 bloody bell
once a day i was just misery i was
losing weight i
it was horrible and i was on steroid and
nothing was working so i was like wait a
minute i'm going to go back to basics
here and i
basically put together a cocktail um
which i've now created a product called
gut food essentially it's three key
ingredients four key ingredients which
is
uh prebiotics and probiotics which
people know about right
so you give them the fertilizer for the
bugs you give good bugs but the next is
polyphenols which are these powerful
plant medicines that are in
food that we often ignore but are
actually some of the most important
things and i talk a lot about
phytochemicals and food as medicine
but certain bugs for example like
cranberry green tea
pomegranate they like these
phytochemicals and it makes them grow
and you can't just take a probiotic
so there's a lot of polyphenols in there
and then the last thing would be
immunoglobulins which is like colostrum
from breast milk so i use
i use that to help rebuild the immune
system in the gut so you put those four
things together prebiotic probiotics
polyphenols
and immunoglobulins you get this
incredible gut healing cocktail
that i've been using on a lot of my
patients with autoimmune disease with
leaky gut
and it's really incredible okay because
i like i hear about that and it sounds
like witchcraft to me but then i've
talked to doctors like in different
specialties
and one of them will say i've seen
immunoglobulins
who was it somebody who works with
microbiome i had them on
dr roucho was like immunoglobulins
really work for people and i
hear people talk about probiotics but
i've always i've never taken probiotics
with prebiotics
because i've always reacted to
prebiotics by themselves
and have always reacted to probiotics by
themselves so you mix together
for so what exactly is a polyphenol and
why would they be so important
oh good point so uh you know in the
plant kingdom there are 25
000 of these phytochemicals or plant
medicines
literally and the rockefeller foundation
is
is um trying to catalog these and study
them with this periodic table
of phytochemicals really just looking at
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
just mapping out all these incredible
molecules
and one class of these molecules are
called polyphenols and they're these
natural compounds that occur in plants
that we're familiar with
the colorful reds greens blues i mean we
know we need blueberries are good for
you like everybody's heard that
well it's because of these polyphenols
like promethoscientins or
you know the pomegranate has you know
elagic acid or the
you know the different things have
different um
phytochemicals that have different
properties and it turns out that
you know we've evolved in concert with
our environment we basically
uh are lazy biologically so we don't
make vitamin c in our bodies we get it
from our food you know guinea pigs
don't make vitamin c but most other
animals make vitamin c so we just
we're sort of biologically lazy and so
we've evolved with eating 800 different
species of plants and all these
different foods
our body uses those molecules that are
their defense systems right so
the plants make these molecules not for
us they make them for their own reasons
in order to actually protect them
against in predators or
to preserve themselves in harsh
conditions or whatever it is
so the more stressed a plant is that
actually the more phytochemicals it has
right a wild blueberry is
far better than and if you know a
factory grown like farm uh blueberry
right it tastes much more sweet and it's
way better
yeah same thing with you know like
anything like if you look at the
heirloom or wild plants
now dandelion greens have hundreds of
times more antioxidant capacity than
spinach for example because they're kind
of wild and
bitter and weird so if you have like
little turtle purple potatoes you know
from peru
they're far more nutrient dense than for
example a big white starchy yukon potato
or
and so forth so i think um the
the uh the key is that we have the
ability to
to use these polyphenols to
benefit our own biology and it turns out
that these bugs
because we ate these things over the
years tend to grow and we really need
these certain bugs in the gut one of
them is called acromaximusinophilia
which is a bug
that produces a mucous layer for the gut
lining to protect against leaky gut
and so if you don't have enough of this
bacteria and you can't really take it as
a probiotic
you get leaky gut you get autoimmune
disease you get inflammation
you may not respond to cancer treatment
and so giving these
polyphenols right cranberry pomegranate
green tea
basically allows you to grow these inner
gardens that are beneficial for your
health
okay so say this um this
bug that produces mucus to help protect
your gut
what happens if you take an antibiotics
like 30 times in 15.
screw it up you screw it up
and you can get that back from food
yeah i mean you know it's interesting
when you take all the probiotics and
stuff you want but it turns out that
your diet is the biggest determinant of
your microbiome
so what you're eating every day and what
you're feeding it you're putting little
pounds of stuff in there every day if
you're feeding it high fructose corn
syrup and
soy refined soy bean oil and all this
crap it's not going to grow good stuff
but if you're feeding it
fiber and prebiotic foods like
artichokes asparagus and jicama and
seaweed and you're
having probiotic foods like kimchi and
sauerkraut or
you're having you know these polyphenol
cocktails or phytochemicals
your gut will grow back a healthy
environment in there and it'll really
dramatically change depending on what
you're eating
so yes um all these other therapies are
important but your diet is among the
most important things
okay and then if you're suffering from
one one last question on this part
if you have some sort of infection so
you had you had heavy metal poisoning
um and did did you find that out through
testing yourself or did you go to a
functional doctor like how
what kind of tests did you do in order
to figure that out well it's a great
question i was sick for a couple years
before i figured out i was actually
uh in hawaii and i ended up uh was at a
conference and i met a doctor who was a
naturopath who said hey come off so
maybe i'll help you figure out what's
going on he did a
machine which is an energetic machine he
tested me so you have heavy metal in my
house nonsense
so i didn't say check so i am going to
get the lab test i got a hair test i got
a challenge test and my level was just
off the chart
so normally i would get worried if
people's levels are over 20. mine was
187.
i was just like you know probably the
one of the worst five or ten i've seen
in
you know 20 000 or 30 000 tests that
i've done
did you find out why yeah well i think
yes because i i
lived in china and i was cleaning out my
air filter every day from highly
concentrated mercury pollution from the
air from coal burning
and probably also a lot of big fish and
also had feelings so the combination of
all of my own genes
i'm not great at detoxifying so i had to
kind of deal with that
but everybody was you know through
learning about it i was able to actually
heal myself and fix a lot of the
problems that i had but but i've also
had lyme disease i've also had obesity
i've had mold so i've sort of had all
the things that
and i've had i've had to see how
nutrition plays a role but even with my
lyme disease patients those who take
better care of themselves who
have better nutrition they tend to do
better like people
often do better when they're when
they're actually taking care of
themselves
okay so taking care of themselves you
mentioned stress
and i've always heard that if you're
stressed
you can get sick and you hear about
people getting ulcers
because of stress and i've just kind of
thrown that off to
witchcraft again i know i'm on a
carnivore diet so it's hard for me to
talk about witchcraft but i still do
so how much i know that it can affect
your sleep but
how much does being under stress
affect you like say it's stressed even
from a job
like can that really be seriously
detrimental
huge i mean if you look at the data on
what is the highest risk of death
it really has to do with we call the
social determinants of health which is
your own sense of control and sense of
ownership and power over your life
and if people feel disenfranchised or
disconnected or have you know
economic stresses jobs stresses family
stresses
it's a bigger predictor of death than
bad diet or smoking
so it's no joke and what happens is that
our bodies are great at dealing with
acute stress you know you
get chased by tiger you run like crazy
and then you're done and that's fine
like you know
there's a book called why zebras don't
get ulcers and the reason they don't get
ulcers is because
you know lion chases them all pit gets
one zebra
this eats it the other ones just kind of
had a panic attack for a minute and then
they all went back to eating their grass
and they were like sitting around eating
their grass while the lions eating their
brother you know
and it's just sort of like the way it
goes they don't stress and have a
chronic stress
we're just chronically stressed so
whether it's job stress
relationship stress financial stress
whether it's the stress of living or
modern culture the divisiveness we're
seeing whether it's the
issues around climate change or social
injustice or whatever the things that
our people are affecting people's lives
you know those create a physiological
response it tends to create disease
so stress is either causes or so makes
worse about 95
of all illness and so dealing with that
aspect of it is really important for
people whether
it's through things like you know uh you
know
meditation or yoga or whether it's
different kinds of like talk therapy or
various treatments that can be done just
having a good friend you know could help
to talk to all that makes a huge
difference
and is are those stress studies they
control for diet and like drug use
because of the stress that's all
controlled for
um well that's a very good point right
because if right if you're stressed
you're
more likely to smoke or eat bad food and
you know eat ice cream if you're
depressed or drink right so it's all
it's all it's tied in together probably
it's hard to separate those things out
but but definitely we know the
physiologic effects of stress when you
when you think a tiger is chasing you
you your blood sugar gets out of balance
right your your body starts to
degrade its tissues so it's it's as if
for an acute
stress it's fine you need these hormones
like the adrenaline and cortisol
but over time you know cortisol will
cause you have muscle loss
sore belly fat make you hungry cause
your
brain to get damaged and cause
inflammation throughout your body and
just it's a horrible a horrible thing to
happen
and it's something we really can do
something about by by learning just
simple practices to help us
achieve a better state of well-being and
health
i'm just selfishly asking you questions
like i've got everything i'm not
drinking i'm
i'm pretty healthy like how much is
chronic stress going to affect
me uh okay you know what
they found when they found that they
looked at you know leaky gut for example
they just took a bunch of young healthy
guys who were super healthy
military guys and they marched overnight
with heavy packs and then they measured
all this stuff and they found they
in the morning they had a tremendous
leaky gut just from the stress of the
physical stress
so it can be psychological or physical
stresses both of those will cause the
same thing
that's horrible yeah
okay okay so there's a reason people
should perhaps
leave their high stress job and go live
in the jungle in costa rica
and chill maybe
or just learn it's more about how you
deal with it right it's more about
how you handle stress right because you
know if you
always joke is if you look at woody
allen has a gun to his head he's going
to be extremely stressed but it's jane
bond he's cool as a cucumber
same gun same stress different response
right so stress is really as defined as
a perception
of a real or imagined threat to your
body or your ego right so it could be a
real threat to your body you're getting
chased by tiger
or it can be an imagined threat to your
ego you think your boss is mad at you
but you just had
you know indigestion from having
something bad for lunch and you
you can have the same physiological
response from both those things whether
they're true or not
and so a lot of our stress comes from
our beliefs and our perceptions and our
view of things that
are unfortunately not uh in line with
what actually is true and we sort of
misinterpret
reality and that creates huge amounts of
stresses
okay that makes sense
um is there is there a reason so you for
your diet you have
vegetables take center stage and you use
meat or that type of protein as kind of
i wouldn't say a condiment
but just as a smaller portion so what's
the reasoning behind
choosing that kind of ratio
well i think for most people you know um
they're going to be able to sort of
optimize their health through eating
a wide variety of colorful plant foods
and and you want to maximize that so for
example for dinner last night i had a
you know palm-sized piece of grass-fed
steak which was on the side of my plate
but then i had you know a big sweet
potato i had a beet salad
i had you know sauteed mushrooms and
garlic and i had
um an actual salad so i had like
let's see beet salad sweet potato
mushrooms and salad
four vegetable dishes and a small piece
of protein
and then so 75 of the food by volume i
consumed was
was or more probably was plant foods and
that's really what is going to help us
stay healthy and it's
low sugar low starch colorful plant
foods i had beet store dark bread i had
orange sweet potatoes i had you know
mushrooms and garlic which are
you know um kind of
you know just like uh got all kinds of
beneficial properties for healing the
body as well
and then salad i put in avocados i put
in kohlrabi which is great for
detoxifying the liver i put in
you know watermelon raw dishes uh and
and
had a really yummy arugula which is also
full of calcium and also phytochemicals
for detox
and it was a really delicious salad and
so i had these basically
four different vegetable dishes which
all had different medicinal properties
along with
sort of a reasonable size of a protein
is probably about 30 grams of protein
for me because i you know i'm a bigger
guy even
more protein um and it's it's a really
way
as it's really a way to sort of upgrade
your health by giving you all this
phytonutrient-dense fiber-rich foods
along with you know high quality high
quality protein
okay so the general the your general
idea and correct me if i'm wrong your
general idea is
um actually we'll come back to that if
somebody is chronically ill and they're
trying to look for a functional doctor
is there a way
to go about doing that because from what
i've found it's actually fairly
difficult i know in canada
all the functional doctors are full
because it's getting
more popular which is good but it's very
difficult to find someone so
yeah yeah it's true you do there it's
true here's the good news
and it's really why i've written you
know so many different books
um is that most of this can be done by
yourself
that if you just focus on
the simple simple principles of
functional medicine and diet
and food as medicine you can literally
have massive transformations i wrote a
book years ago called the ultra mind
solution which is about how to fix your
mind
mood and so forth by fixing your body
first and i had in the book you know a
series of questionnaires and little
steps
about what to do for each thing if
there's out of balance and you know
basically foundational principles for
healthy living
and and it really worked for people and
then i i
i had a patient come in after i'd
written the book and
and it was quite a while after maybe a
year after it
and i said well why here so i'm okay i'm
like well why'd you make an appointment
so when i made an appointment
i was really sick but then i followed
the principles in your book
and the an outline and everything got
better
you know you didn't really need me i
said why'd you come say well maybe i
thought you could give me some more
you know more advice but but i was like
a lot of patients do get better
without actually having to see a doctor
so i encourage people to start with
things like
elimination diet or start with some of
my books on how to sort of maybe attend
a detox diet and see what's left over
because like if you if you all of a
sudden cure everything
within a few days or a few weeks by
shifting your diet that may be the issue
but if you don't you might need to go
deeper
and then then you need to see somebody
which is tough and i think there's the
institute for functional medicine
ifm.org and you can go on the website
and find
a doctor in your area that's great um
but
a lot of stuff can be done just through
self-care and supplements and
and uh it's sort of the foundation and
if that doesn't work you gotta
try to find someone and stuff okay
switching directions
you have how many books did you say you
you read you've read
written i think i've written 17 i have
to count
okay so you have 17 books you have a
massive social media following
and you see patience yeah still yeah so
how do you how do you manage to do all
that you're like
just completely moving away from health
just as like more of a business
person um how do you manage to fit all
that in
well i mean the good news is i have
great teams so i have a wonderful team
in my practice that runs most
things and i just get to do patience
i've set it up so it's sort of on
autopilot
uh which took a lot of work initially
but now i really can
you know my practice manager runs
everything i dip in cleveland clinic i
have a whole great team there
my digital team i have a wonderful team
and i do the things that i do best
and so i do the writing i do speaking i
do teaching
i come up with the ideas the concepts
but then you know if i want to create a
website for this i want to create a
product for that i just sort of lay it
out and then my team kind of executes on
it so it's really about having
the network and support and team that
makes it all work out
but i but i also make sure i take care
of myself and i i make sure i meditate
and exercise and eat well and
enough sleep and have the connections
and friendships and love that
it's important to be healthy and i and i
should sort of balance it all out
and uh often very lucky as well like i
feel
you know i can i can sit down and i can
crank out a book very quickly because
it's all in here i've been seeing
patients for 35 years and i
have so much going on in my head so i
it's not hard for me to sort of focus
and really just drop in and and
put the information out there so i'll go
in very intense
birds so i'll just like work for 12
hours a day i'll exercise eat sleep
and then kick saunas as teams and then
right that's
it uh how long have you been
did you start doing functional medicine
right away after you
became a doctor or did you get really
sick and then go into functional
medicine
yeah well you know i always was
interested in nutrition i studied
nutrition in college and read this book
called nutrition against disease by
roger williams which was so powerful
and so i've always had my thinking
shaped by alternative therapies and
healing i was a yoga teacher before i
was a doctor uh
and but then i you know kind of got
traditional medicine in my head and was
practicing that and working the er and
delivering babies and you know pretty
good just general all-around family
doctor
and then i got really sick i was about
36 and i just
my system crashed with the mercury
poisoning and i really had to do
something different
and so they began to sort of i got a job
at canyon ranch actually before because
i wanted to do more wellness stuff
but then i discovered functional
medicine it was in you know in 1996
and that was you know 25 years ago i
guess and the rest of history i just
dove in with both feet and and realized
that this was a really new field that i
think they were
they're still sort of formulating what
it was and how to do it and how to teach
it but i've been involved all the way
along with
with uh bringing it out to to the public
have you got a lot of negative kickback
for what you're telling people
of course you know my my badge of honor
is that i'm on quack watch you know one
of my books oh yeah
that i'm so angry about that website
i'm no it really hurt me when i was
doing research when i was
really really really ill i was trying to
figure out
my way out of this disaster that was my
health
and everybody i i looked up that i
thought okay well maybe this makes sense
and i'd type in their name and be like
no this is a scam artist
and i discounted so many doctors that i
now respect because they were on that
horrible website i'm so angry at that
website because
it really put me back a number of years
because i was still
trusting mainstream narratives i guess
yeah it's unfortunate um it's really
unfortunate i i wish
that is somewhere different but we we
will get there we'll get there i think
uh
it's you know we see places like
cleveland clinic and other places
understanding that food is medicine that
we need to be focusing on this so i
think i'm hopeful
that's good you sound more optimistic
than me although it is getting
it this stuff is spreading right social
media has helped a lot
completely i mean from where i was 25
years ago no one ever heard of it don't
know what it was
people like are you crazy what are you
doing leaky gut oh you're
quack you know like now it's oh yeah
okay it's not a major medical journal
with major
medical institutions it just takes time
yeah
yeah i wish it didn't uh okay
raising kids so you talked a little bit
about how
30 of births now are c-sections and
when you're told that you're told you
need the c-section right like a lot of
these aren't electives they go and they
go oh
a whole bunch of things are wrong have a
c-section and it ends up giving you this
30
c-section rate how much of disease
nowadays do you think
is caused by either like in having us
being born from a c-section or hit being
hit with antibiotics as a
little kid or like you said um
nothing against immunizations but the
fact that there's a lot of them when
you're really really
little coupled with what you mentioned
perhaps formula and if you look at
formula it's a complete disaster
um so how much of this is starting off
you know within the first couple of
years
i think we you know look we now have one
in six kids born with a neuro
developmental disorder we've gone from
born autism
yeah we've got one one one we just have
one in
like 3 000 kids with autoimmune with
autism and now it's you know one in 39
boys you know i mean that
and and so how do we how do we even
begin to kind of deal with that
and and i think when you look at it's
not one thing it's it's
it's a whole pattern of sort of the
modernization of our life right so it's
development of all these
agrochemicals uh and toxins in the
environment
uh petrochemical derived products that
are everywhere flame retardants
pesticides are besides
glyphosate you know heavy metals around
and so you look at you know it's the
average newborn and this was studied
done by the environmental working group
where they looked at 10 kids and they
did all their blood work and everything
from the umbilical cord blood they were
287 known toxins in the umbilical
cord blood and there are
our two i think 211 are neurotoxins
um so so this is just when the kids
are born without even having taken their
first breath breast milk is also full of
stuff unfortunately
and then of course c-sections affect the
microbiome the antibiotics
and then the food the kids are eating
all the the additives and chemicals and
pesticides and sugar and processed foods
all that damages our nutritional status
our immune system our gut
and so that's why you begin to see
there's just some massive amounts of
obesity in kids and massive amounts of
of
of all kinds of chronic inflammatory
diseases and allergies
and depression and add and autism it's
like
wait a minute like what's happening here
to our children and i think
we you know if we were really looking at
this carefully
and seeing what we're doing to our kids
if a foreign country were
doing this to our kids what we're doing
we'd go to war to protect them right
i mean we wouldn't stand by while you
know a foreign
country poisons our kids makes them fat
makes them sick and like we would be
like no
but here we just sort of go along with
it because it's the traditional american
diet and processed food is just so
prevalent you know how much of it is
reversible
like what happens if you find out i get
parents messaging me and they go
you know oh i was on this diet i had no
idea i thought i was doing the right
thing and my kid has
these health problems and i'm pretty
sure it's because of what i was feeding
him for the first couple of years is he
doomed yes
um um you know i think there's a lot you
can do to repair and i think people can
get repaired
um but i think we just need to sort of
double down on
on on getting our kids healthy and what
i'm surprised at
which is how resilient kids are so i've
seen kids with autism with severe
allergic diseases autoimmune diseases
and when you get these kids swapped out
from real food and getting them
you know fixing these underlying causes
they just respond so well
and they do so so great and they can
really reverse a lot of these
things have you seen something like
anaphylaxis resolve itself
that's trickier um that's some you know
it's a more complicated condition where
we see you know
your immune system just goes crazy with
what we'll call an ige response which is
a true allergy it's not like a
sensitivity i'm like a little sensitive
to gluten it's not like that you like
get a peanut allergy and you get you
know all kinds of
crap that you're getting that just
causes your immune system to go crazy
and that really is something that we can
do something about
by often healing a leaky gut we can
reduce the amount of anaphylaxis we can
reduce the amount of inflammation in the
body i've seen this
so it's not going to necessarily cure it
but it can really help to kind of calm
the whole system down
so if someone's immune system is just
constantly irritated aggravated
and it's often because of some of the
underlying factors like food toxins
nutritional status
and there's also some evidence that by
fixing a leaky gut you can
really help to reduce this in other
countries for example like the
developing countries
there's almost no hives and allergies
and anaphylaxis and
it's just like if you're a hunter
gatherer it's just uh there's no
autoimmune disease no allergic disorders
no asthma
and that's because they're exposed to
all these different bugs because they
have a different microbiome
because they may be even exposed to
things like worms and it's interesting
the algae part of the body
the ige also is a thing that fights
worms
so there's a theory called the epidemic
of absence that if you don't have
any of these sort of natural things
we're all exposed to historically
our immune system is going to get poored
and distracted and they go
attack us instead of attacking the bug
so there are therapies called helmet
therapies which are using worms
in medicine and there there's research
going on around in duke and other places
so i think we're sort of you know and i
i've actually used
worm therapy in certain select patients
who have really bad
allergic or anaphylactic issues and they
do get better so i mean we're still
learning about this but
i think it's a pretty cool whole future
strategy
you've seen that work what kind of worms
are you using ah
not just any worms it's like you don't
go get an earthworm and have to eat it
but
there's certain rooms that are not for
example um
human worms that can take up they won't
take up residence but they'll pass
through like a tourist and change the
environment in there so what does the
pig worms
there's uh there's pig worms right that
some people are using but there's also
rat tapeworms uh called htc's
hdcs can be very effective and they're
they're they're tasteless they're small
you don't see them
you just have a little vial full every
two weeks and uh
and and see if you can help your system
i've seen you've seen it really work for
people so
i'm sort of excited about that
witchcraft
might work though it might work i've
looked into how i mean i've looked into
everything to try and make myself less
sensitive and i've looked into
i've looked into that type of theory
yeah i think it could be
it could where if you do have ige
reactivity and anaphylaxis and hives
then
actually it's something worth
considering uh because there is no other
quote therapy other than just fixing
your gut and overall getting healthy but
it is one of those things that seems to
really respond i've been shocked to see
the eye
levels drop tenfold in patients getting
these worm therapies
that's insane so do you think the worm
is actually is doing something or is the
immune system getting used to having
some foreign invader so it just calms
down
well i think you know there's a lot of
different theories about it but you know
it's like the you know if you if you
it's like a dog who gets sort of bored
in the house and starts chewing up all
the furniture
it's like you know somehow the immune
system is used to being busy managing
all these worms and stuff but
when they take them away and they've got
sterol basically you know does not
have a lot of exposure these things
maybe for some people
it causes problems and you know when you
see like for example
a country in sardinia for example
there's really high rates of ms
but they also had really high rates of
malaria and it turns out that the
protective gene
for malaria also can tend to cause ms
if there's no malaria right so you take
away the malaria there's no malaria in
sardinia but they still have this gene
and they're all getting a mess right so
we really are
sort of learning about how this sort of
bug immune response works but
apparently you know our bodies really do
okay with
exposure different things as long as
we're over time
able to actually develop the proper
immune response to them
and i think that's what we happen in
people who live on farms people i mean
kids who grow up on farms
don't have allergies don't have asthma
tend not to have eczema
you know they really don't have
autoimmune diseases so many of you grew
up on a farm because you're
you know living in the dirt and you're
doing poop that's okay
like we are way too sterilized and
that's why we're seeing so much of this
inflammatory stuff
that is so interesting well thank you
very much for coming on
where can people find you online oh they
can find me at mark
at drhyman.com d-r-h-y-m-a-n-dot-com
and they can also find me social media
dr mark heim that's d-r-m-a-r-k
hyman and instagram twitter social media
i've also got a podcast like you it's
called the doctor's pharmacy
uh wherever you get your podcast it's
doing really well it's off in the top
hundred of all podcasts and
top five ten of all the health podcasts
usually so
i think people will enjoy that and uh
yeah i'm the ultra wellness center in
linux and
you know just find me anywhere great
well thank you very much that was
interesting
yeah thanks so much for having me and
hopefully people will enjoy the pagan
diet and
be able to get not so confused about
what to eat anymore
you